Did you know one of the things that we used
to cover on the show regularly before gay
marriage was legalized nationally were all
sorts of wild claims from religious right
people about all of the terrible things that
they thought gay people were doing.
And this ranged from gay people are indoctrinating
children into being gay.
Children are being convinced to be gay by
gay people, to all sorts of things.
I don't even want to say because I don't want
this video to be monetized.
This type of thing died down a little bit
when gay marriage was legalized nationally
and the anti-gay focus shifted to so-called
religious freedom.
But things are now coming full circle, and
once again, these wacky right wing politicians
are getting into the same sort of stuff again,
and this might be one of the most ridiculous
ones I've seen.
This happened yesterday.
This is an interview with newly minted Trumpy
and Republican Congresswoman Lauren Bobert,
whose big issue has been she wants to carry
guns on the floor of the House of Representatives.
She went on something called the War Room
and or Real America's Voice.
I don't even fully understand what this is.
And she stated, I hope you're sitting down.
She stated that the Equality Act currently
being worked on in Congress is really a bill
for gay and lesbian supremacy.
And she believes that it is being this is
her word.
It is also being carried out by trans vex
hike's.
Transvestites, hike's, yes, that's her word,
not mine.
Take a listen to this.
We can't say the same for the so-called Equality
Act, which we all know that that's just the
Democrats are using a play on words.
There is nothing about equality in that act.
If anything, it's it's the it's it's supremacy
of of gays and lesbians and transvestites.
I mean, that's what this is about, is about
putting them higher than anyone else.
It's not about equality of trans vacs hikes
that that is really something else.
This is what happens when you elect people
who know nothing, stand for nothing and bring
nothing to the table.
But they supported Trump and that's why you
voted for them.
This is this is what happens.
And I've talked.
But this applies to Marjorie Taylor Green.
This applies to Madison Cawthorn, people who
basically run social media offices.
They don't run policy offices.
They run social media offices.
And of course, this is embarrassing.
It's homophobic.
It's disgusting.
It's pathetic.
It's all of the different things that we've
known these folk folks to be for a long time.
But I'll take this as an opportunity to talk
a little bit about the Equality Act.
It's not about trans vex hyc supremacy.
And of course, the word is transgender.
I want to be clear that it's not just that
she's mispronouncing the word.
The word we use is transgender.
But one of the most important things that
this bill would do is it would amend the 1964
Civil Rights Act to explicitly prevent discrimination
based on sexual orientation and gender identity.
I've spoken before since gay marriage was
legalized nationally in by the Supreme Court
decision.
There are still many states in which you can
discriminate against people based on their
real or perceived sexual orientation that
is not banned federally at this point in time.
This act would ban it, and that's extraordinarily
important.
The Equality Act would also expand protections
for protected classes beyond just employment
and housing.
It would cover any federally funded program.
It would include public accommodations, which
means retail stores, stadiums and other venues.
Yes, this does relate to the anti-gay cake
baker.
It would impact that sort of situation.
And the playbook for opponents of the Equality
Act is very predictable.
And we're seeing it there with Lauren Bobert.
It's assassination of character.
It's, I guess, also creating new words like
trans vacc hike's.
But it's also saying that the bill goes too
far.
It's saying the bill threatens a businesses
or people who might have legitimate religious
objections to serving LGBT individuals in
their businesses.
Now, the bill does need 60 votes in the Senate.
It's unclear Democrats can find ten Republicans
to get this done.
We know you know, we talk about it's the same
conversation.
Maybe Susan Collins, maybe Lisa Murkowski.
Mitt Romney has already said he's not going
to vote in favor of this in the Senate.
Rob Portman is unclear whether he has any
interest in voting for this in the Senate.
So it looks much like the same old story we're
going to observe and see.
But trust me, this is not about trans vex
hyc supremacy.
That's the last thing that this is about.
And we'll have more coverage of this bill
and covid relief and H.R. one on our Instagram
page.
Find us at The David Pakman Show on Instagram.
Follow me on Instagram at David Pakman as
well.